alright gotta start with most important
story of the week Vanity Fair released
pictures from the set of Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens so there's a
there's a bunch of pictures here Adam
driver who is in girls he's gonna play
kylo Ren I think he's gonna be the bad
guy Lupita Nyong'o is going to play mods
kannada Marisa name Toria here a bunch
of galactic travelers and smugglers
oscar isaac is gonna play poker on and
daisy ridley is gonna play ray alright
so I've been saying how I don't like
this idea spoilers I think it kind of
ruins these things and yet I just did it
here so what does that say about me I'm
not so sure so what have to talk about
Star Wars that much but generally and we
know can we can do i know i'm i'm good
but what do you guys think of like oh we
live at a time when everything sort of
gets spoiled like there's no surprises
anymore like i watch the trailer I love
seeing Harrison forward back and
Chewbacca and stuff but like everything
kind of gets pre spoiled these days
doesn't it this is really a spoiler
because we're getting them from Vanity
Fair there from the studio they're not
like leaked right so I wouldn't call it
a spoiler but in terms of like surprises
it's true that we now get a lot more
information early on the thing that I
hate is that we get casting information
very very early so like for TV shows if
a character's leaving we find out like
six months in advance because we know
about the contract negotiations yeah
things that we used to not know about it
also really like takes away from
surprise of that yeah do you miss the
surprise we have no surprises anymore
because of social media and this stuff
right I feel like people like need every
piece that they can possibly acquire to
try to piece this story together
themselves so it totally takes up you
know the whole reason that you're going
to the movies man I personally try to
just never watch anything yeah ever just
my eyes ever yeah so that nothing can
ever be spoiled you yeah what captured
your guys imagination the way Star Wars
has clearly captured mine is there
anything that did it for you that way as
a kid as a kid as an adult or I mean
what are our Star Wars you know so Star
Wars did it for you yeah yeah I mean I
watched the original trilogy when I was
young yeah and and I think that I was
young enough that an episode one came
out I wasn't totally horrified by it
like I was a
a bit like excited to see a Star Wars
movie in theater how old are you in the
wind 1 the Phantom Menace I was 13 so
that's young enough that it still work
like on the cusp of being like a little
bit bratty about it but I mean it was
terrible but I like remember like seeing
at my parents and kind of being excited
and like jazzed about it because you
know waned in mind for three hours and
it was like a Star Wars experience then
afterwards that kind of like look on
their faces when I realized it like oh
this was actually really bad and I
should get better right right what would
happen it for you um you know I was
really into the Ghostbusters that was
really i really do had first and second
things are you excited for the all girl
hello yes Kristen Wiig it doesn't get
better than that that's amazing yeah I
would construct little cardboard boxes
and throw them into the middle of like
my mom talking with her friends in the
living room as the ghost catching bugs
are creating my own that's right miss
suck in the evil in the room I guess
you're so cost effective I can't get
over this Oh would you ever cross the
streams um oh yes all the times I'm
crossing the streams right now yeah buts
why I'm take what we've taken our
relationship to the next level yeah
anyway clearly our most groundbreaking
story ever now what do you what do you
guys think there's all this stuff does
it ruin the surprise this thing's not
coming out till Christmas so we still
have like six months or are you okay
with getting it kind of leaked and
learning a little bit about the story
and the characters before head let us
know your thoughts in the comments right
now
you